inflation and a major new effort to tamp
down those rising prices the federal
reserve has announced the biggest
increase in its key short-term interest
rate in more than 20 years that rate
going up by half a percentage point all
part of the battle to rain in prices
which of course have been rising for
most americans i mean take a look at
this since march of last year the cost
of food energy
and gas have all seen major increases so
the big question is will the fed
strategy work cbs news business analyst
jill schlesinger is here to tell us jill
good morning good morning well this move
was expected and it's intended to thread
a very precise needle we're trying to
see if the fed can ease prices without
triggering a recession or job losses now
that half point increase for short-term
interest rates the largest since the
year 2000 and it aims to do two things
one we're going to see if the fed can
remove the economic boost that they
provided during the covid recession and
two as we've been talking about for a
long time they're trying to fight
inflation and that inflation rate is
increasing at the fastest pace in more
than four decades so this hike means you
may see interest rates rise on
everything from credit card balances to
new auto loans adjustable rate mortgages
even some small business loans good news
investors cheered that the fed is going
to be able to execute this strategy that
it's on target after a brutal april and
we all felt that brutal april and early
losses to begin the day yesterday all
three major stock market indexes soared
by roughly 3 percent on the session so
tony good news you can stop texting me
and you can actually check your 401.
that's right because i want to retire
like tomorrow exact time
it's not quite time yet all right so
that is the fed strategy i understand
that now how quickly could it work for
people well it will start to work within
months meaning that it will be mean that
the inflation rate will stop going up
but prices are going to remain high for
probably 6 12 maybe even 18 more months
the fed strategy is a two-year strategy
and we're just at the beginning of this
process so it went up relatively slowly
to a new high and it's going to take
some time for it to come back down you
betcha all right jill thank you very
much okay nate and i checking our 401
case too
about it very much still always good to
see you